I always good everybody we are we're
here with BuzzFeed and we're gonna
answer some questions of our first time
yeah first time you dance in front of a
crowd right the first thing that I dance
in front of a crowd I think it was in
London the show wasn't good first memory
that comes to mind when it comes to toy
oh I feel like when I went to the ER was
very special I saw my grandmother you
know it was a first Americans to left
you there was a Panama City and so first
I think was it's a magic I wanna see her
in the lake I was super excited
first up you put got the words mister
actually I messed up in the in lawanda
oh it was the first live show and I mess
up like cuz I supposed to do I don't
know and I go to another way that's
happened you know you have to learn it
in wrestling you know these all you guys
there you know first big purchase after
you became famous and because bodily
just like stuff in my house they like
believe the daiquiri and stuff like how
to their TVs I like this name no matter
but first I'll be check when you wake up
sir what's up on the group
conceal what goes on the group chat you
guys not allowed to know what we have in
your future breast cell phone you ever
in owned Wow the flip phone with with
Nintendo Motorola yeah yeah by like
super old that the flip phone that you
could use as a walkie-talkie as well
when you put a little blush yo what's up
yeah Eric first present usual after
performing shower first time you realize
you were famous when I do a show in my
country but the liquor I am and I see my
old friends my family and other fans
there that was like ever a really cool
yeah
first okay I think it was either victory
justice or space was right now four or
five that I was dancing in this TV show
so the and there was this like my
dancers and I had to choose between the
pulpit you like The Bachelor okay wait I
was super super it was yeah one of my
friends my first kiss is on YouTube it
was in our music video of solo yo pretty
good my first kids is was a great it was
a legacy so I I have to act like a bad
boy you know so I just give her two
after that she was my girlfriend one
month
I always good everybody we are yes you
know that was so much fun and we check
out more because she love you
Jenelle Burton
[Music]
[Music]